Alex machinski creator of a
multi-billion dollar fraud known as
Celsius has been arrested I can't
express how big of a deal this is not
just for this channel which has been
covering this for over a year but mostly
for the victims here's what some of them
said about this fraud only a few months
ago so this was an absolute fraud from
the beginning I mean it turns out that a
lot of these businesses that they claim
to be propping up Celsius were
completely fraudulent from what I've
seen from The Examiner more and more it
looks like it was just a a textbook case
of a Ponzi scheme I don't care if it was
a Ponzi scheme from the very beginning
or the very end it still was a Ponzi
scheme it doesn't matter it meant to
start a Ponzi scheme right but the
second you've got into those
circumstances it it becomes fraud they
were basically losing money from the
very start of the company and they're
literally lying in front of everyone's
faces saying yeah oh it's totally fine
yeah you could totally keep our money in
here yeah I would totally invest more if
I could as they're currently at that
same time withdrawing funds as they're
looting on camera lying with everyone's
face he made a lot of egregious claims
on his Twitter on his website on his
podcasts he would do claiming uh if
Celsius ever went bankrupt all the
customers would get all of their funds
back you know there's tweets of him
saying that and as a CEO of a company
you would take that word at face value
you would believe him when he says your
coins are going to come back to you and
now that everything's coming to light
and showing that essentially what he was
running as a Ponzi I do believe he
should face showtime and the people that
were also involved with it that were
enabling that behavior
well it looks like that's exactly what's
happening Alex machinski is facing
serious prison time so let's get into
the meat of these allegations today the
doj SCC cftc and FTC All released
indictments against Alex machinski
Celsius itself was fined 4.7 billion
dollars and seven criminal charges were
alleged against Alex machinski himself
including Securities fraud wire fraud
and Market manipulation now in total
mashinski faces up to 115 years as a Max
sentence but of course the sentence will
likely be much lower even so though
machinski is 57 years old so there's a
chance he will be in prison for the rest
of his life because of Celsius and it's
not just him being charged either Roni
Cohen pavon the chief Revenue officer at
Celsius is also facing criminal charges
and the reasons for that aren't
surprising as we've stated over and over
and over Celsius had been secretly using
customer deposits for years to buy their
own own stupid cell token and make the
price go up which benefited insiders
like Alex machinsky and Roni Cohen pavon
who sold their cell tokens and became
very rich 42 million dollars for Alex
and 3.6 million for the lawyer and most
of that money was the direct result of
lying to their end customer over and
over they lied to cover up the fact that
they were the main buyers of cell token
and Main sellers they lied about their
Ico making 50 million dollars they lied
about giving 80 of their revenues back
to Celsius customers they lied about
Alex machinski not selling cell token
they lied about Celsius being profitable
when they knew they were bleeding cash
and look I could go on and on but there
are 71 mentions of the word false in
this report so we'd be here all day the
point is this Alex machinski and his
co-conspirators lied in order to get
more people to deposit money while they
cashed out this sell token they knew
they were in insolvent they knew their
business wasn't working and still they
continued to pretend it was They
promoted this Ponzi scheme built on
unrealistic returns and when it all
crashed they made sure their money was
out and for those of you who've been
watching this channel over the last year
this won't come as a surprise as I said
we've been covering a lot of these
allegations but I also want to be clear
that some people have been calling out
Celsius even before we did a fellow
investigator Dirty Bubble media has been
calling out Celsius for months before
anyone else knew they were insolvent and
I wanted to speak to him to ask how he
knew so early and what we can learn from
it and what this indictment means my
name is James block I write Dirty Bubble
media a Blog focused on fraud in the
cryptocurrency space to be quite honest
I thought that Celsius was a fraud
very early in my encounters with it
within a few days of actually learning
about the project and really what clued
me into it was learning about its
founder and CEO Alex machinski's history
he made a lot of big claims about his
his past successes the companies he had
founded and what I found pretty quickly
was that he had lied or at least grossly
exaggerated pretty much everything that
he told people about what he had done
before founding Celsius and in my
experience when someone lies that much
and that often they don't stop lying
what isn't this indictment represent to
you these indictments of vindication for
me really it it um kind of confirms what
we knew for a long time and you know I
expected this to happen I don't know if
it took longer than I expected but it
took a year to the day of them filing
for bankruptcy for them to charge him
with um with fraud thanks for coming on
I think you helped a lot of people I for
one am just grateful that the victims
are finally seeing some form of Justice
in this and that outright crimes are
being treated as such and so it's with
great pleasure that I want to wrap up
today's show in a bit of a unique way
today I'm announcing the addition of
Alex machinski to the Wall of Shame as
you guys know when you appear on this
show and then face charges we will name
you and we will shame you hopefully it
encourages would-be scammers to think
twice banks are not your friends
but Alex is your friend yes well Celsius
does is really helps people navigate in
a safe way into this environment so when
you use a Celsius wallet you know okay
I'm gonna earn yield and I'm gonna stay
safe in the safe environment because
Celsius already did the homework and
figured out what's safe we have billions
of dollars in liquidity so anyone who
wants to withdraw that's that's the
service you can withdraw at any time
foreign